mine robot c'est le nom du robot
construit par cinq élèves de la première
S1 du lycée du mondurville de MPa il
participe au premier challenge robotique
scolaire organisé par la ville
d'lancours une heure par semaine avec
leur professeurs d'informatique pendant
4 mois ils ont construit leur robot et
ont appris à le coder et le programmer
ce projet il nous a permis de travailler
en équipe d'apprendre à programmer donc
c'est une interface nouvelle on
connaissait pas ça avant la plus grosse
difficulté c'est pour pour ce projet
c'est de le faire tourner donc on a dû
créer un programme spécial pour le faire
tourner et la à tous les autres la
plusvalue pédagogique c'est que on fait
plus cours chapitre 1 contrôle chapitre
2 contrôle on fait du projet donc soit
le projet on réussit soit on réussit pas
comme dans la vraie vie ça leur apprend
à s'organiser à travailler en
équipe à prendre en compte la vie des
autres plus de 400 élèves de
l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin en
Yveline étaient présents ce matin pour
l'occasion au Palais des Sports de MPa
de la maternelle au lycée chaque groupe
présentait son projet pédagogique
celui-ci pouvait être accompagné d'un
projet artistique pour que les jeunes
développent compétences scientifiques et
techniques de façon ludique
Saint-Quentin et dans les h zones
mondiales classé par le mit dans
l'innovation actuellement aujourd'hui un
robot on est à 1 % de ces possibilités
demain il sera à 100% donc il s'agit que
les enfants comprennent ça etlaborent
s'empar s'approprie cette nouvelle
culture qui fera marcher les usine de
main donc voilà on les forme tout de
suite à à à être les meilleurs
techniciens à être des ingénieurs de de
de de cet avenir qui arrive bien sûr sur
le monde avec le numérique un juré
composé d'ingénieurs de représentants de
l'éducation nationales et des différents
partenaires a récompensé les lauréats de
chaque catégorie de la maternelle au
lycée chaque vainqueur a pu repartir
avec son robot les lycéens ont même eu
la chance de remporter un mini
drone